what do you think about this new like
current trend of just video essays okay
so you may you've made some long video
essays before right I can't imagine how
much work they take but I've noticed a
trend where video essays have just
gotten longer and longer to the point
where it's just like now we have like a
four hour video essay uh
um there's like eight hours yeah yeah
yeah yeah
um and yeah it's a lot dude I watched
the six and a half hour tokimeki
Memorial breakdown video which is like
one of the best it was amazing it was so
good incredible I don't even know what
that is but I'm willing to give it six
and a half hours because if someone is
that passionate about a topic that
they're willing to do six and a half
hours of editing then I'm I will watch
it it's very action button
um and that's the guy makes sense called
Tim Rogers and he's been a journalist
for like ever so like he really knows
his [__] and he is really knowledgeable
and he's the perfect kind of person to
make a video like that he's also just
really [__] funny and stuff yeah I
hate that guy
in terms of like the the like larger
Trend to be honest with you like
I'm never gonna make an eight hour video
but hell if someone can do it and keep
it compelling more power to them like
I'm sure there's a lot of I don't know I
didn't know someone could make a two
hour Garfield video or something like
that but I mean like you know I'm sure
there's a lot of bad eight hour videos
I'm sure there's a lot of one hour bad
one hour videos I've probably made some
of them you know it's like fans be like
oh well actually
yeah but I think um it's very easy with
YouTube to get caught up on what other
people are doing and I think ultimately
like the healthiest thing is if there
are just lots of different videos being
made in lots of different ways and
lengths and styles and like they're not
all gonna be for you but they don't have
to be yeah it used to be that like you
mentioned earlier like if you made a
bleach video or you made an anime video
about you were normally the one video
and it's kind of getting it kind of used
to be like that generally about a topic
but now when there's like a kind of a
cult game or a cult kind of piece of
media everyone's kind of scrambling to
to make a a long form essay video about
it the discussing you ever like have to
consider or if someone else makes a
video you're like ah I can't make my
video no because I feel like if I really
make a video right no one else would
have made that video the way I would
have made it yeah you know because like
I'm never gonna do like uh review of
Starfield because I don't [__] care
it's like I'm never gonna make a video I
don't really give a [__] about it and if
I really give a [__] about something
it's not going to be like anyone else's
and that's that's not unique to me
that's like anyone who's really gonna
put their own individual take on a video
yeah absolutely I mean sometimes you've
made a video I'm like [__] John can do
it better than any like than I ever
could I can never make it yeah your
Bucky video I'm like well [__] I can
never make a Bucky video again I would I
would [__] kill
video
videos
but like I did it well because you're
watching the end product of what I did
if that went through your pipeline and
your PR dude that video would be [__]
hilarious what are you talking make a
bakkie video
shut the [__] up
fans of each other
no I just want to see a makeup
that's why he's the goat man that's why
he's the goat has ever been someone in
who is in your community who has just
been extremely persistent emailing you
to make a video about one topic and has
not given up oh constantly yeah and on I
like there's one guy
and I think it's
it's like this this Lego thing I think
it's called zoids yeah I've been getting
emails from him for about six years and
um like I never know what's video from
you would be [__] old I don't know
anything about it and I just look it up
and I'm like what the [__]
and he's real but like the thing I
always say is do you know who should
make a video about that him and it would
probably rule yeah you know if he took a
fraction of the time he spends writing
me emails and made a video about it it'd
probably be class you know you know
that's you know you brought up a very
interesting point of how you started
YouTube which is if we've said anything
to piss you off in our videos like it
let it cook and then just do it John and
just make a video make a video
yeah man make a career out of it you
know end up on an extremely successful
podcast for reasons you're not quite
sure
no do you do you ever Miss like old
animation like no
um I mean I feel like any tube there is
because our audience is so new and so
yeah different I feel like it doesn't
hold the same weight I think that it
doesn't know to you that it might have
to deal with I mean any tube for a time
was actually a genuinely I think really
special interesting thing and like you
know a lot of great videos came out
about that and like it did really deepen
a lot of my understanding about anime
and like just how to appreciate media in
general yeah it's also just a lot of
[__]
a lot of petty [__] yeah that's just
a lot of like well I think this and it's
like okay that's cool and then it's like
well no argue with me
the whole Space is matured right yeah I
think so that's when people start making
their livelihood on it you're like
actually no I I don't want to ruin
Someone's Child yeah or get in fights
with people I feel like it's I just want
to work and like it does get to the
point as well though where like it is
hard to deal with any kind of like um
conflict in a fair way because I don't
know if you ever have the thing where
like someone will like I don't know say
something dumb on Twitter and then
you'll be like you'll you Tweet back and
you're like listen mate you're being
silly and then every then like 40 people
who follow you are like yeah he's right
you're being silly and you should
[__] die that's like well now I
didn't say that you know you're really
paraphrasing yeah no yeah that's why you
know sometimes you get a comment you're
like I want to respond to you yeah maybe
that's why some people have alt accounts
you know so so because like World count
is weak sorry it's weak to have an all
together yeah but sometimes I just want
this person to know that I disagree with
him without millions of like my like it
almost feels like when I have like
followers that back me up I'm like guys
I don't need your help I got this okay I
got this okay don't don't worry don't
worry there's always going to be that
the your platform and size behind it
there regardless no exactly
I I have like responded to people like a
bunch of times and like more than I
should have and every time I always
think it's gonna feel great it always
feels just bad yeah
there's that instinct you know where you
just see like a really [__] take and you
can just feel the vein in your forehead
thickening yes
the fury comes like a clever comments
there's five minutes where you've
drafted the Tweet but you don't post it
on the most powerful this powerful
mental
a wrestler who I think has found this
really beautiful solution to this
whenever anyone talks [__] to him on
Twitter he goes on their profile he
finds a picture of them he copy and
paste the picture and just replies with
that
that's so cruel
oh
this year this is often the people who
have like the most weirdest uh fetish
porn [__] on their account that took the
maddest [__] of course yeah uh yeah I
remember a guy tweeted something at me
that was rather insulting and I was like
[__] is this guy I click on his profile
and it was like it was like inflation
porn only and I was like what the [__]
this guy you're dealing with a man who
has nothing to lose
I mean it's it's a meme but it is always
the anime profile pictures as well it's
the Kyoto animation profile pictures oh
it's you know you know that's all too
well John
never understood the the like overlap
there just these really positive anime
about these girls learning to play music
and befriend each other it's just
[__] most insane people you will ever
meet yeah I love it and you know you can
always tell when you piss off like a
fandom because you know it I I just
there's just some sort of irony in here
where it's just a person criticizing you
for you know talking about bleach or
something and it's just like the the
most obvious bleach fan accounts who
just like goes home sleeps worships Kubo
yeah I remember one time the best the
best example of this I've ever gotten
was someone got really mad at my shenmue
3 video yeah
and um I think so and uh critical
consensus was that it's bad yeah yeah
but you know that what are the critics
but like look if someone someone is not
like d-legitimate for liking that yeah
I'm not saying that but this person they
had shenmue in the title up there
thumbnail with the kill but I I um
responded back to them just being like
okay person with shenmue in their tag
but then when I looked at their profile
picture
them with
um the it was them with you Suzuki the
maker of shenmue so this person I think
it's you Suzuki maybe I'm [__] that
up no it is and it was so like actually
yeah like it was them at a fan meet and
greet with that person
and
look Becca illusion yeah yeah you're
never gonna change a man's mind yeah